let's do some word problems as you can
see my handwriting has improved
dramatically i've been practicing no i
actually just figured out that i could
actually type on this thing anyway so
what does this word problem say
jamie picked 17 flowers and lindsay
picked 12. they gave away 20 of the
flowers how many flowers were left let's
think about this jamie picked 17 flowers
let me draw that
so jamie picked 17 flowers
so let me draw something that represents
the 17 flowers that jamie picked
this is kind of my traditional
singapore bar
let me make that in yellow
and the length of this is going to be 17
and the units are flowers 17 flowers
and then what does it say it says
lindsay picked 12.
and so let's just think they're saying
well you know one person picked some
flowers another person picked more
then they gave away 20 of the flowers so
it sounds like they're saying you know
they combined their flowers gave 20 and
how many were left so what we want to do
is we want to combine the flowers that
jamie and lindsey picked so lindsay
picked 12 flowers
so lindsay's flowers so we're going to
combine them
lindsay pick 12.
so that's lindsey's flowers right there
she picked 12.
and so first of all how many total
flowers did they pick well 12 plus 17
that's 29
let me put that in a neutral color so
the total flowers picked or is 29 right
17 plus 12 2 plus 7 is 9
2 29
and then i say they gave away 20 of the
flowers so they gave away 20 of the
flowers what color do i want to do that
in i'll do that in
blue
and green no no i already used green
i'll do it in brown so they gave away 20
of the flowers
they gave away
20 of the flowers how many flowers were
left so they gave away 20.
so we could view if that's their total
and if they're they gave away
20.
so let's say that this is
what they gave away
that's the flock well i didn't want to
do it like that
oh no i didn't want to do that
especially
i didn't want to lose the window
no boy everything's self-destructing now
there you go okay
let me draw it with the traditional way
so say they gave away 20 of the flowers
so it's going to be something like that
that's how much they gave away 20 and
i'm overwriting by 29.
all right so how much do they have left
so they they had 29 the whole length of
this thing is 29 they gave away 20 of
them
so the amount that they're going to have
left is this
right or the difference between 29 and
20. right this distance right here is
20.
so it's 29 minus 20. well that's nine so
they have nine flowers left let's do the
next problem and now we're on page 37 of
the book
let's see how well versed i am in typing
let's see if i can pull this off
that's like my typing window
and i'm going to it says 125
children
took part
in a
mathematics
54
of them
or gir not grills girls
how
many
more
boys than girls
were there
were there there you go how many boys
more boys and girls were there so let's
see if we can handle this one
125 children took part in a mathematics
so that that tells us the total that's
the boys plus the girls is 125
right
125. 54 of them were girls so how many
boys were in the competition so if we if
we do boys and girls and i'll use
stereotypical colors because i don't
know any better
so this is the number of girls
so that's the number of girls
which we don't know oh no we do know
that's 54 there are 54 girls
54 girls that's given here 54 of them
were girls
and then we have some number of boys
which is unclear
draw that
so we have some number of boys
which we don't know
boys
but what we do know is that the boys and
the girls combined are 125.
so we know for example
that this entire number
is 125. the boys plus the girls are 125.
so how many boys are there
well it's essentially going to be
the difference between 125 and the
number of girls
so
boys is going to be equal to
125 minus the number of
girls
and we could minus the girls
right and think about this actually this
is kind of a little bit of pre-algebra
this statement actually comes directly
from the fact
that boys
plus girls
is equal to 125 right this is called an
equation an equation just says well what
i have on the left side is equal to what
i have on the right side
and then essentially if boys plus girls
is 125 if i took the girls away from
both sides of this equation i get this
right here
right if i took the girls away from this
side i get just boys on this side boys
but if whatever i do to one side
equation i have to do the other so i
have 125. so i did minus girls here but
i also have to do minus girls on this
side and that's where i have the 20 125
minus girls if that confuses you ignore
it but just think about the fact that
the boys and the girls are 125 and
that's the same thing as saying 125
minus the girls is equal to the boys
and we know that the girls are 54. so
we'll say b for boys is equal to 125
minus 54.
and let's work that out up here in this
corner
so 125
minus 54.
5 minus 4 is 1.
well we have to just essentially 12
minus five so it's 71.
so the boys are 71. so are we done
well no
they didn't ask us how many boys are
there they asked us how many more boys
than girls are there so they want to
know the difference between the boys and
the girls right so what's the difference
between the boys and the girls
so it's essentially going to be the boys
minus the girls
equals what well we know the boys are 71
boys and we know that there's 54 girls
and i you could do that in your head but
if you don't want to do that in your
head let's do that in the corner up here
so 71 boys
minus 54
girls
let's see so let's borrow a ten so that
becomes a six
that becomes an eleven
eleven minus four is seven
right i always have trouble with eleven
yeah eleven minus four is seven six
minus five is one
so there's 17
more
boys than girls and if we actually were
well i won't worry about that let's do
the next video
i'm excited about my ability my newly
found ability to type these things
let me do it in a new color
let me do it in a bold yellow
let me make the typing box
that's my typing box
and what does it say
ali
collected that's actually the name of my
cousin who
figured out a new way to subtract
numbers without borrowing but anyway ali
collected 137 stamps
he collected
27
stamps less
than his sister
how
many
stamps
did they
collect
all
together
okay
so in order to figure out how many
ali and his sister combined collected we
have to figure out how many did this a
sister collect we know ali collected 137
so we have to figure out how much his
sister collected well how do we do that
well he collected 137 let me draw that
ali collected 137 stamps
so we can make that with a little bar
like that
and the length of course is 137 that's
how many stamps ali collected
and it was 27 less stamps than his
sister so if i were to draw his sister's
stamps
you know i would be i could do it this
is a singapore math style so it's going
to be more right ali collected less than
his sister
so sister collected
more stamps
and how many more did she collect
well we know that
he collected let me do that in a
different color so it says
he collected 27
stamps less than his sister
so the difference between the amount ali
collected this is ali
and his sister
that these numbers clash is kind of
hard to look at but anyway the
difference between ali and his sister is
27 stamps
so this distance or this difference is
27 stamps so how many stamps oh so how
many steps did a sister collect well
think of it this way the difference
between ali's
sister stamps and his is 27 or you could
say ali stamps plus 27 is equal to the
sister stamps so how many does his
sister collect
so this
this length right here
is going to be 137
plus 27
what is that 7 plus 7 is 14 but the 4
here in the ones place and then we could
say carry the one or just write the ten
it's four plus ten so put the ten there
one plus three is four actually this is
ten plus thirty is forty plus twenty is
sixty
and then you bring down the hundred
so she collected 164 stamps
fair enough
now they want us to know
how many stamps did they collect all
together and i'm picking my color how
many unless that's too similar to a
color i've already used
i'll use this one how many
stamps
did they collect all together so
essentially they want to know how many
total stamps the ali
plus his sister
how many stamps did they collect well
ali collected 137
the sister we just
calculated collected 164 stamps so we
just have to add these two numbers and
that's the total number of stamps and
you could almost do it as you took this
bar and you put it beside this and
measured that total length but anyway
what's 7 plus 4 it's 11. put the 1 in
the ones place put the 10 or the tens
digit in the tens place
10 plus 30 plus 60 is 100
that's zero tens and one hundred
or you could say that one plus three
plus six is ten carry the one either way
hundred plus hundred plus a hundred is
three hundred
so all together they collected
301 stamps
i will see you in the next video